cougar town is having these final season
and you directed I did an episode
directed a couple episodes I really
enjoyed it I don't think the cast
enjoyed it at all really yeah that's
weird because you've been a cast member
all along and then suddenly you're
raised to this position of telling them
what to do and I'd really loved it yeah
did you behave appropriately plan first
of all first of all you don't think the
crew everybody's like what's he gonna be
like as a direct is he you know so to
diffuse things a little bit I rest up
mm-hmm
for my first day of directing how God Oh
old-timey directors outfit oh you did
yeah it's exactly I've always thought if
I ever directed anything and God knows
no one's ever gonna ask me but if I ever
directed anything I would do I would
dress I've always thought the same thing
I would dress like one of those 1920's
direct I didn't just dress it I mean I
was like now action see ya and as soon
as I get a new actor like the first time
Courtney like said aligns I let her get
about halfway through and I just yelled
god that's horrible
you call that acting they were all does
I think we have a picture here of you
being a complete ass
[Laughter]
[Applause]
see here you'll see that's the kind of
thing we like you'll through in this
town
you